une fois de plus ils sont à côté de la
plaque je m'intéresse pas la cuisine
mais quand on regarde top chef c'est là
qu'il ait mis si tu faisais les tests de
la cuisine
oui alors qu'en cas d'émission il ya un
suspense il ya un lit il ya des
éliminations un chrono et c'est alors
que là ça pourrait très bien un bouquin
la cuisine des stars mais en émission ça
ne s'est pas un objet télévisuel
voilà vous vous posez une question jean
michel debruyne à côté de la plaque
est-ce que vous avez vu l'émission mais
lorsque non - oui non mais tu es ce que
vous avez vu l'émission est ce que je
suggère répondre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui ou non cette émission j'ai fait mes
mails à des landes où chefs des autres